[Music]
there is a Grandeur here this place this
performance this home of Chinese
political power
the national people's Congress is an act
of careful choreography an annual
political Gathering a mass rubber
stamping of decisions made behind closed
doors
and center stage of course was the
president confirmed this week to his
third term and he kicked off this new
era with an uncompromising message to
the world
we should strengthen National Defense
and army modernization building the
People's Army into a great wall of Steel
it effectively safeguards National
Security sovereignty and development
interests
[Music]
this is his brand now increasingly his
calling card China's strength in the
face of a hostile threatening West and
its position he can pursue with
confidence his power has never been
greater his position all but
unchallengeable what has happened here
this week has largely been about
entrenching the power of one man
president XI has promoted his allies and
pushed his agenda he wants the world to
know it is his assertive vision for
China on the world stage that it now
needs to reckon with
and a reckoning has rarely felt closer
as relations with America spiral the
real heat is here in the Strait of
Taiwan the self-governing island China
sees as its own it's the key reason say
experts Regional defense alliances like
orcas make it so angry Kenneth thinks of
focus as a collective effort by the West
uh to keep China in check and China has
been uh trying very hard to convince uh
countries in the region that this is uh
not good
image matters here in XI jinping's China
so much is airbrushed and sanitized but
the danger of this standoff is as real
as it is serious and positions are
increasingly entrenched Helena Smith Sky
News in Beijing